Mm,
it's interesting question,
what is sort of impossible to define,
but sociologists have tried and their
definition I think is really useful.
Their definition is that coolness is a
measured positive rebellion against an
illegitimate mainstream and like
thinking of that all in one big pile is
a little bit complicated,
but when you disentangle that it makes a
lot of sense.
It is a measured small rebellion.
A little difference or distinction from
mainstream that is considered
illegitimate or bad.
Coolness is a response to a mainstream.
It is in many ways very similar to the
sociological definition of a cult.
A cult is also a measured rebellion to a
mainstream that is considered
legitimate.
Maybe the best way to think about this
definition is to think about it through
the lens of dress codes for high
schools,
right?
Lots of high schoolers when they attend
a school that has addressed code,
they try to break from that code,
but only in ways that are measured and
positive.
Right?
So the dress code says you have to wear
a coat with a tie and a button up shirt.
Maybe they'll undo the tie a bit or wear
a hat or undo their button up shirt.
They'll have measured,
measured rebellions to that illegitimate
mainstream,
but it's not cool to go to school naked.
It's not cool to go to school dressed in
some like,
you know,
like some sort of weird superhero for
Tuesday.
That's not a measured rebellion that is
outright rebellion and that is not
considered cool.
So you need a measured rebellion,
number one,
but number two,
the mainstream has to be considered
legitimate in the first place in order
for the action to be considered.
Cool.
So in one study,
these researchers is something really
clever.
They told a bunch of students who are,
who were departing from the mainstream,
a dress code,
and in various ways they told them the
dress code was a initiated to honor a
high school graduate who had died
overseas in a war.
Now suddenly that dress code wasn't
legitimate.
It was a completely legitimate way for
people to honor a fallen soldier and
fewer students considered departing from
that dress code to be cool.
So it's very important to think when
defining coolness that you need two
parts.
First you need to mainstream that is
considered bad.
People need to agree that the mainstream
is bad,
and two,
you need the rebellion to be positive
and measured.
It can't be crazy.
It can't be insane.
And when you have those two things
together,
you have cool the difference between
that which we consider cool and that
which we consider cultish because
they're relatively similar things.
They're both departing from a mainstream
is essentially degree.
That culture all designed around this
idea that most human beings are,
most people in society don't get you or
they don't get this important thing.
They're not religious enough,
they're not thoughtful enough.
They're not environmental enough has to
be sort of the first principle of that
cult.
But we reserve the word cult for
essentially groups that are too far away
from the mainstream to be considered a
measured rebellion from it.
And so I think that's exactly the right
way to think about coolness versus
cultish Nus,
is that we're all part of cults were all
part of scent.
We all disagree with some aspect of
mainstream social or political thought,
but the but whether or not other people
consider us cool there cultish
essentially depends on whether they
think that we are departing from that
mainstream in a way that is measured and
positive.